les 450 brebis de laurence gaudet ont
beau avoir passé la nuit à l'abri dans
la bergerie
l'éleveuse n'a pas pu trouver le sommeil
depuis le début de l'été louh a déjà
attaqué deux fois son propos elle vient
encore de perdre neuf bêtes
laurence son mari et leurs enfants sont
à bout parce que
j'ai des images qui restent pour marquer
parce que normalement voudrait les
ressortir qu'on pourra pas l'air sortir
parce qu'on sait pas ce qu'on fera au
printemps parce que on sait pas comment
passera l'hiver
donc on ne sait plus on sait pas combien
de temps pourra tenir les premiers comme
ça parce qu'on pourra leur donner à
manger
et franchement au jour le jour quoi et
là ça commence à être difficile
lors de la première attaque en juillet
dernier le lou avait été filmée grâce à
un piège photographique et des tests adn
avait validé sa présence
l'animal a sévi sur plusieurs communes à
cheval entre l'yonne et l'aube voisine
mais à mon avis pas tout seul pour faire
un travail comme ça et pas tout seul
mais s'ils sont plusieurs
la dernière attaque est la plus
importante et la plus spectaculaire 9
brebis ont été égorgées dans ce prêt à
quelques mètres seulement des
habitations presque au coeur de la
commune de quoi alimenter la psychose
chez les habitants ils vont avoir peur
d'aller par exemple aux champignons
d'aller se promener dans les bois je
pense qu'ils vont dire bien sûr scoop
bec à bec avec le look est ce qu'on fait
parce qu'ils vont se poser la question
on n'est pas habitué à voir des
prédateurs comme ça sur notre secteur en
france le loup est une espèce protégée
et il est interdit de la battre dans le
tonnerrois et l'yonne il va falloir
apprendre à vivre avec la présence et la
menace de ce prédateur